in August 20 20 I am going to turn 50
years old and I'm not waiting until my
50th birthday is to start making some
long-overdue changes in my life as a
matter of fact on my 49th birthday I set
some goals for myself one of which was
to really start getting back into shape
and going to the gym regularly and to
lose some of the excess weight that I've
accumulated over all these years in in
large part through a sedentary lifestyle
which is very easy to do as an academic
and as somebody who does a lot of his
work behind a desk so one of the ways
that I'm trying to do that other than
going to the gym is by using healthy
wage which is a website in an
organization that allows you to bet on
weight loss goals that's what this is
about and I'm gonna come right up front
and tell you there's a healthy wage
challenge that you can get in on if you
want to this is the last day for my
particular challenge if you want to use
the link below and piggyback on my own
weight loss goals you get an additional
$40 tacked on to your bet and I get some
tacked on to my bet if you join up so if
you're interested in doing that then you
might want to check out the link let me
tell you why I'm doing it I actually
tried healthy wage two years ago in 2017
and I found that I wasn't able to get
myself to the gym as regularly as I
wanted to we also had a lot of family
and life issues going on I was also
teaching a lot so the work-life balance
wasn't working out and I failed my
challenge and when you fail your
challenge you've put money into it that
that's sort of the incentive that they
are you going into it you bet on
yourself and if you make your
weight-loss goal then you get your money
back and you get some other money in
tacked on to it if you don't make your
goal it goes back into the kitty for all
the other healthy wage people
which I'm fine with that so around New
Year's they sent out a little challenge
saying well you know do you want to try
again
this is available to those who've lost
their wager before we'll tack on an
additional amount to sweeten the deal so
I said okay I'm you know working out
fairly regularly not as much as I'd like
to do but 2020 is supposed to be the
year where I actually do start doing
that so why not get in on it and my
particular goal for healthy wage is to
lose 30 pounds over the course of nine
months entirely doable provided I
actually stick to what I'm supposed to
do which has to do in part with diet the
diet stuff you know cut back on midnight
snacks eat a little bit healthier maybe
you know some portion control it's not
like an cut out drinking or anything
since I don't do much of that anyway and
then there's the exercise I have been
going to the gym fairly regularly and
doing the weights circuit which is great
I haven't actually lost any weight doing
it but I've replaced quite a bit of fat
with muscle and I already feel quite a
bit better but then I also have to add
in cardio workouts and some Yoga for
flexibility and some other things as
well by the way not looking for any
health or fitness advice from anybody in
the comments I'm just telling you what
I'm doing for that and the goal for me
is to get up to five to six regular
workouts per week and to walk everyday
I've done that in the past and managed
to lose anywhere from thirty to forty
pounds when I did it in my late 30s
early 40s so I'm pretty sure I can do it
again especially over the the space of
nine months the main reason I want to do
that is not so much about looks or
anything like that I'm fortunate that
I'm in a great relationship with a wife
who likes me no matter how I look right
I mean it could be nice to be
to fit into my my old suits and things
like that but I have I have clothes that
fit all right it's mostly about being
healthy and feeling good and extending
my life you know this is a period where
there's a fateful decision to make if I
if I don't really get the exercise down
as an integral part of my life well then
I can expect to have a shorter life and
since I want to enjoy my time with my
family and friends and I want to make
some contributions in my field and I'd
like to travel around and things along
those lines I really have to get serious
about the exercise so healthy wage is a
way to do that I have other things that
I do going to the gym is a little bit of
me time where I get to listen to classic
metal so there's an incentive for me I'm
not yet at the point where workouts are
actually fun my wife as I head off to
the gym will say have a great workout
and you know in my mind I'm thinking
great workout is a workout that's
finished and then when she come when I
come back she says was your workout good
and I said it was a workout so that's
good but you know it's it's getting
better and I do remember a time where I
actually did enjoy working out so I'm
looking forward to that so all that said
if you in this month when we typically
make goals for the year ahead want to
get in on the healthy weight challenge
I'm pointing up 50 bucks a month betting
on myself that I lose 30 pounds which is
a little over 10 percent of my body
weight in nine months if you want to
make a bet on yourself you can use the
referral code below healthy wage will
give you a little boost onto your bet
they'll boost my bet as well just good
for today so if you're watching this
video later on that's already passed but
I think that it's a good thing to do
anyway so you might want to go check out
the website just to see if it
something that you would like and I may
shoot some additional videos about
health and working out and fitness along
the line over the course of this year
depending on whether I make any progress
or not most likely because if I don't
that I probably won't want to shoot
videos at it but you know this is
something that I think it's time to
actually take seriously more seriously
than I've been taking it in the past and
to finally get myself not necessarily
back into the shape that I was in in my
teens and 20s that's probably an
impossible goal but at least good shape
for somebody who is in the middle part
of their life to try to turn this into
what it used to be the prime of one's
life
you